[Music]
while working as the archivist of my
collection of curiosities i've
researched a lot of cryptids famous
monsters like bigfoot and the yeti but
also lesser-known creatures like the
sheep squatch and the loveland frogman
as a methodical archivist i have to
admit that a lot of the evidence for
such creatures as amazing as they are
can be somewhat questionable
indeed there's a long and frankly
hilarious history of people trying and
failing to fake the existence of these
cryptids to the masses so today i'll be
unveiling some of the greatest
historical cryptid hoaxes and while the
monsters on this list are fake the real
stories behind their fabrication are
often just as outlandish as the
creatures themselves involving lies
double crossing and ridiculous amounts
of money down the drain
so let's shine a light on these stories
in the summer of 1937 reports of giant
footprints on the shores of nantucket
shocked the tiny u.s town
photographs of what appeared to be the
tracks of a large unknown animal soon
followed stories spread that a sea
serpent right out of ancient myth had
come ashore somewhere on the island a
few days later an account came in that a
gigantic monster was spotted on the
beach and huge crowds gathered to
investigate and they were greeted by
this
a sea serpent to be sure but clearly not
a real one this hilariously fake
creature was the creation of this guy
tony sarg an early pioneer in puppetry
who had orchestrated the whole thing
footprints included to get the town and
himself into the news
although even at the time people
obviously weren't fooled by the giant
inflatable monster once they actually
saw it sarg's self-promotion plan was a
success later that year he'd actually
end up designing the first balloons of
the macy's day parade which his fake sea
serpent also flew in
the nantucket sea serpent is a pretty
amusing and harmless hoax all in all
but not all hoaxes have such pleasant
backstories in new york in the early
1840s a reported 10 000 pamphlets swept
the city claiming the body of a
real-life mermaid had been found and was
going on display
the location of this supposed unveiling
was a museum at the corner of broadway
and park row which just so happened to
be owned by one p.t barnum the infamous
showman conman and all-around
questionable dude and this mermaid was
right out of his scheming playbook
though advertised as a beautiful being
from classical myth the actual specimen
people would see was a strange shriveled
creature that horrified onlookers this
is because barnum's mermaid was of
course not a supernatural creature but a
hoax the object was in fact composed of
the body and torso of a taxidermied
monkey attached to the back half of a
fish in a pretty twisted attempt to
create a natural looking life form while
the scientific community at large
debunked the specimen multiple times the
mermaid was still a huge success for
barnum with people from all over coming
to examine it
the hoax met its end when it was likely
destroyed in one of the many fires that
destroyed other parts of barnum's
collections and so the mermaid scam was
no more
but other cryptid hoaxes were far more
enduring perhaps no single faked image
has influenced more people than this
famous 1934 photograph that supposedly
captures the one and only loch ness
monster this photo is a huge part of
what launched the supposed sea monster
into popular culture and led to
countless follow-up articles and other
alleged sightings it wasn't until much
later that the picture was officially
exposed as a fake and the tale behind
why it was taken is truly ridiculous
the story of the hoax begins in 1933
when the newspaper the daily mail hired
one marmaduke wetherell pictured here
looking extremely normal to track down
the beast a british actor turned
eccentric big game hunter weatherell
reported a series of footprints
belonging to the creature yes footprints
at this time the concept of the loch
ness monster being fully aquatic wasn't
completely in the public consciousness
and a lot of supposed sightings from the
era involved the beast lumbering across
dry land wetherill's footprints were
ridiculed by the daily mail when it
turned out he had faked them by pressing
the taxidermied leg of a hippo into the
sand looking to get back at the
newspaper wetherill paid his son-in-law
to take a photo of a wooden dinosaur
head glued to a toy submarine from a
distance this hoax made for a decently
convincing monster and the rest is
history
not all cryptid hoaxes were so cheap to
produce however others like the
petrified cardiff giant were extremely
costly and complex undertakings and
deception the grand illusion began two
years before the mysterious giant was
unveiled when an american named george
hull hired a german sculptor in secret
to carve a ten foot or three meter long
block of stone into the likeness of a
giant he then transported the stone
giant by a railroad to the form of his
cousin where he buried it nearly a year
later hull hired two men to build a well
where he knew his fake petrified giant
had been buried in total this elaborate
plan likely cost over 51 000
in today's money but hull soon made his
money back as people from across the
country scrambled to take a look at the
supposed giant the giant drew such
crowds that another con man hired
someone to model the giant shape and wax
and create a plaster replica that conman
was pt barnum again showing that guy was
really everywhere
once barnum started making money off his
copy of the giant hold tried to sue
barnum in court calling barnum's giant a
fake reportedly the judge told hull to
get his giant to swear on its own
genuineness if he wanted a favorable
ruling in the end both giants were
revealed as fakes in court quite the
series of twists
other equally wild hoaxes emerged from
much more peaceful backgrounds the
cottingly fairies appear in infamous
photographs taken in 1917 near the small
english village of cottingley these
photographs feature what appear to be
various fairies interacting with two
young cousins and are extremely bold
compared to many of the other hoaxes by
not being blurry in the slightest these
photographs had a profound effect on the
public which at the time was
experiencing a rise in interest in
psychic phenomena as part of an escape
from the horrors of the first world war
sir arthur conan doyle most famous as
the author of the sherlock holmes
stories was a particularly passionate
advocate that the photos were genuine
many were more skeptical however as
close examination of the photos made it
seem pretty clear the fairies were
actually just paper cutouts positioned
so they appeared to be interacting with
the children while believing the photos
were real might have been the far more
appealing option interests soon died
down and eventually the two cousins
admitted that the photographs were
cardboard cutouts copied from popular
children's books of the time nonetheless
it's a fascinating moment of history
not all hoaxes were debunked so easily
however the pilt-down man is perhaps the
greatest hoax on this list in terms of
how long it was accepted by the
scientific community though not
encrypted in the traditional sense this
fossil supposedly belonged to a missing
link between apes and humans the tale of
this missing link begins in 1912 when
charles dawson an amateur scientist who
should not be confused with the way
cooler charles darwin claimed to have
found a skull that would fill a supposed
gap in paleontology regarding human
origins the majority of scholars in this
emerging field believed his finding to
be legitimate and reconstructions of the
piltdown man became famous
nationalism and cultural prejudice
played a role in this as the piltdown
man satisfied the expectations of
british scientists that the earliest
humans must have emerged in europe even
at the time however more thorough
paleontologists were skeptical from the
outset with some suggesting the skull
was actually just the cranium of a human
stuck onto the jawbone of an orangutan
this assertion turned out to be exactly
correct and was proved definitively in
1953 with charles dawson being the
likely culprit behind the forgery from
the outset the missing link concept of
the piltdown man was grounded in an
outdated understanding of evolution as
something strictly linear and
progressive our modern phylogenetic tree
of hominid evolution is way way more
complex with there being no solitary
missing link between anatomically modern
humans and our anthropoid ancestors the
pill down man is therefore an even more
obvious hoax in retrospect
and the last hoax on our list is
something more harmless and quite a bit
more recent the pacific northwest tree
octopus is encrypted from the early
internet age it emerged on the scene
with this website which encouraged
readers to help save the endangered
tree-dwelling octopus species of the
temperate rainforests in north america
the tree octopus is obviously just a fun
joke but thanks to the many doctored
photographs on display a lot of people
thought this was a real animal this
website actually led to early
discussions on how easily the internet
can trick people into believing false
information an idea that is commonplace
now
the creator of this hoax who goes by the
pseudonym lyle zappado is an early
mastermind of surrealist internet humor
and i've dropped a link to his site and
social media in the description below
because out of all these cryptids the
tree octopus is definitely the most fun
and my personal favorite
and with that i've covered some of the
craziest hoax stories i've found while
doing research for the archive if there
are other cryptid hoaxes that you're a
fan of please let me know in the
comments
also thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this entry please lend your support and
like subscribe and hit the notification
icon to stay up to date on all things
curious see you in the next video
you